this video is brought to you by
squarespace the best way to make an
amazing website hey guys it's max we
just got in the brand new galaxy s21
ultra and today we're gonna do a full
detailed comparison against the note 20
ultra
and find out if it's worth spending
hundreds of dollars
more for this brand new phone or if you
just get the note we're not only going
to compare the exterior differences
comfort and hand and specs but other
things such as the brand new display
with higher brightness and refresh rates
the new fingerprint sensor
the brand new 5g chip the cameras and
much more
now the first thing that i noticed is
the design difference it almost looks
like there's two different companies
designing this phone
on the back the thing that really stands
out are the camera bumps
the s21 looks huge with all these
cutouts now
we will be looking at cameras today in
this video but we're also doing a blind
camera comparison
those are always a ton of fun not
knowing which camera shot which photo
and choosing which one looks best so if
you guys want to see that click that
subscribe button below
and with that you guys can help us reach
600 000 subscribers
before march which is our two year mark
that would be amazing now in my opinion
the note 20 looks
a lot more premium and more elegant i've
been using the s21 for about a day now
and it just looks
almost like it's dated like we're going
back in time
we have the standard kind of curve
design with the standard edges
whereas the note 20 ultra you have this
super slim
frame here with the curved glass and
then these flat tops
so in the hand i love resting my finger
on it
and with that it also feels much thinner
than the s21 which feels chunky and it
feels heavier
at the same time and overall i will say
that the note 20 is a little bit more
comfortable
in the hand and now let's go ahead and
compare the fingerprint sensors as you
guys can see
the fingerprint icon right here is a
little bit larger because we do have a
new sensor
and it's supposed to be a little bit
faster more reliable so let's go and
test that out
i'm going to do just one by one so as
you guys can see
as soon as i put it down bam that is
nice and quick
no problems there let's try this one
all right press a little longer let me
hold still really really fast
let's test them at the same time all
right so
the s21 is slightly faster screen's off
about the same all right
so then the note 20 didn't turn on there
all right so it looks like
if everything is working perfectly your
fingers in the correct position
they're about the same maybe just
slightly faster on the new s21
but there you go it didn't go off again
you just have a little bit more leeway
with the new s21 now the next thing that
we're going to cover are the displays
and man this might be the biggest reason
to go for the new
s21 ultra but before we take a look at
all of the differences
let me give a shout out to the sponsor
of this video squarespace
if you've been thinking about making
your own website squarespace is
seriously the best way to go
we've built multiple sites and you can
too with literally
no web making experience you just choose
a template customize blocks of text and
images
and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple it's affordable and
ours have been running flawlessly for
years now
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
for
literally anything else go to
squarespace.commaxtech for a free trial
and use our custom link down below and
when you're ready to launch you will
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
and now let's compare the displays now
looking at both of these
i can't really tell a difference in
terms of sharpness or detail
even though the s21 does have a little
bit higher
resolution but with that said right now
i have the s21 in 120 hertz mode
whereas the note 20 is only at 60 hertz
and that is because when we go into the
settings and we go
into the display and we turn on the
adaptive motion it actually won't let
you do that unless you turn down
your resolution from that nice crisp
high-end 1440p down to 1080p
and now that i have 120 hertz on both
yes i can tell a difference
the text on the note 20 looks a little
bit soft
and there's almost a little bit of i
don't know weirdness around the edges
because it has to
change the resolution it's not matching
up to the display and because of that
i mostly ran the note 20 in at 60 hertz
mode
in the kids do both at the same time
which is awesome
and you guys can see the smoothest
difference in the slow motion clips
how much smoother 120 hertz is compared
to 60
it's a really noticeable difference and
there's more differences than that
so samsung is using a newer display
technology and the s21 can go all the
way down to 10 hertz meaning
when we're just sitting here it doesn't
have to refresh at 120 or even 60 or 30
and that saves you battery life with
that the viewing angles are also a
little bit better as well
and there's a little bit less blue shift
but it's not a huge difference
and as far as brightness we also have a
difference here you guys see i
maxed out both of them and the top
camera i went ahead and turned that down
so it doesn't blow out the screens and
you can tell that the s21 is
brighter now it has a peak brightness of
up to 1500 nits which is
crazy we'll test out a hdr video here in
a second
but when you max it out manually it
won't reach that you have to be outside
in auto mode
but anyways you'll get a little bit
brighter now the standout feature of the
note series has always been
the s pen where you can have it stored
right inside the phone there you pull it
out
you get a little pop-up and there's a
bunch of different things you could do
you can create notes or you could just
doodle this one's ar
doodle and you've always needed to buy a
note for that
but now with the s21 for the first time
you can actually use an s-pen now as you
guys could see
it actually does work with one that came
from a note
but they do have an additional one that
they sell right now it is currently sold
out
the only downside if you want to use it
is that there is nowhere to store
inside the phone itself so you're either
gonna have to put in your pocket or get
one of those cases
that have a little spot for it and now
let's put these ola displays to the real
test i have some
4k hdr footage here there was a s21
update this morning so both can play
this back at 1440p
and with that they fixed the hdr and now
it is nice
and bright and vibrant and as you guys
could see
it is actually better than the note 20.
it looks a little bit sharper to my eyes
the highlights are a little bit brighter
and the same thing kind of goes for the
contrast or at least it's
very close so as far as hdr video
the new s21 is definitely
a better experience but with that said
what about the speakers so let's go
ahead and compare them
please go get a pair of headphones if
you have some so you guys can hear the
differences
and let's take a listen
[Music]
started
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below i want
to hear your guys's opinion
now as far as what i heard man they were
so similar this might have been the
closest i've ever heard
in terms of phones now there were a few
differences
the note 20 is a little bit louder and
the highs are a little bit brighter
which probably is what makes it louder
where the s21 has a little bit more bass
and a little bit more of richness
in the mids but it's also slightly
quieter but overall
i don't think anybody will complain with
either one and now let's compare the 5g
speeds i'm gonna go ahead and click
go they're both connected to the same
server
the same tower and the reason i'm doing
this test
is because the new s21 ultra has the new
snapdragon x60
which is a five nanometer chip it's
supposed to be faster but as you guys
can see
that was a big difference right there
this one's still downloading
but the speed did hit higher now
with the faster speeds it also is
supposed to sip a lot
less power or use a lot less power it
looks like now we're going for the
upload test
and they're roughly the same so this is
the second time we're doing this test we
did it with the iphone
and both times the s21 is slower which
is
weird now the weird thing is that the
s21 is showing lte
on the actual speed test app so i went
ahead and i ran this
again and as you can see the results are
fairly
similar to the first time now both are
showing 5g in our speed test
app so so far this is fairly consistent
i want to go ahead and do
one more run here but this time i'll let
these run one at a time to make sure
there's no
interference or anything like that and
bam look at that now the s21
is hitting those nice high speeds and we
are in a concrete building right now so
it'd be much faster outside
and let's see what the note 20 could do
running by itself
and bam we're reaching those high speeds
and actually
a little bit faster oh now it's cutting
down never mind
so it does look like for some reason
the note 20 is faster so we have 138
compared to 101
and 101 isn't bad you'll still get great
speeds with the s21
as long as you're not right next to a
note 20 user
pulling data at the same time now let's
get into processor and graphics
performance i have geekbench 5 opened up
right here
and it's interesting to see that the
frequencies are actually slightly higher
on the note 20 ultra so let's go ahead
and run geekbench 5
and one big difference between these two
is that
the new s21 ultra uses a five nanometer
processor so it should be more energy
efficient
and more powerful we have the 888 over
here compared to the 865 plus
so we have a result and i have to say
that this is kind of
embarrassing i was expecting a much
bigger difference now sure
on the single core that is about 14 but
we're not only talking about
a half year difference this is a whole
architecture change going down to five
nanometers
and all the on the multi-core that is
literally a five percent
improvement so it definitely is not
worth buying the s21 ultra
for the performance gains at least in
cpu now where i'm really curious
is for gaming so let's go and switch
over and do a graphics test
we have gfx bench open i'm going to
select the car chase scene we're going
to be able to watch
the performance difference as we're
going so let's go ahead and hit start
let's flip these the s21 loaded it quite
a bit quicker
and now let's see if we notice any
performance differences honestly both
are looking pretty smooth there's a few
sections where i can notice some dropped
frames
but it's not as big of a difference as i
expected of course in a second here
we're gonna know the actual results and
the frames per second that we got
all right we have a result and wow okay
i guess my eyes were correct we have
29 frames per second compared to 34
so that is super close pretty much an
insignificant difference and i did
notice a few drop frames like i
mentioned
but almost the whole time it was just as
smooth so
that is also unfortunate that we're not
getting much performance difference
with this brand new flagship processor
now there still is one major benefit
with the snapdragon 888 and the new x60
modem and that is
battery life so i've only used the s21
for about a day but the battery life has
been awesome
and from what i've seen online you'll
get about two to three hours
better screen on time compared to the
note 20
and that is with having that 120 hertz
on
or if you shut both of them off so the
battery life is absolutely
incredible and now it's finally time to
talk about the cameras now both these
are flagships
they have crazy 108 megapixel sensors we
have
40 megapixel front-facing sensors here's
a selfie shot with the beauty mode
turned off you guys let me know which
one looks better down below but the most
interesting thing for me
is the telephoto cameras so
not only do we have this crazy 10x zoom
which is now 10x optical zoom compared
to five times but the s21 also has
a new three times optical zoom camera
now i figured that that extra camera is
probably great for macro shots
but take a look at this and you guys let
me know your thoughts but to me
using the digital crop on that 108
megapixel sensor actually looks
better on the note 20 ultra and my next
thought was that it could be used for
portrait shots instead of having digital
crop
but no both of them still use that main
108 megapixel shooter
and you guys let me know which one of
these portraits look better to you now
of course there's so much to cover
in terms of camera we also have 8k video
we have stabilization
a ton of stuff so that's why we're doing
that blind camera comparison i'm gonna
go out and shoot a bunch of photos today
and then vadim and angelica are gonna
guess which one looks better
and we'll know is it the more mature
product with lots of software updates
or this new phone with a little bit of
hardware changes make sure you guys
enable those notifications down below
and now let's talk about the value
and my final verdict on which one i
would personally
buy as far as prices the new s21 ultra
it is 1200 bucks so i actually dropped
about 200 bucks compared to last year
which is great
and the note 20 it was 1300
with that said there are some killer
sales right now
i'll leave some links down in the video
description you can pick one of these up
for about a thousand dollars and i've
actually seen them slightly less than
that
compared to full price of 1200.
not only that with the note 20 you
actually can add a micro sd
card so you can expand your storage
without having to pay extra
out of the gate which is awesome and
samsung ditched that
with the s21 and to make matters worse
the s21
also doesn't come with the charging
brick which the note 20 does include and
then of course
even though you have support for the s
pen with s21 it actually
comes with the note 20 and you have that
nice little convenient slot
to store it in and to top it all off the
things that i was most
excited about with the s21 ultra
which is the new snapdragon 5 nanometer
chip and the new modem
well the performance isn't that much
better and the actual 5g
was slightly slower for some reason so
with that said
there is absolutely no way that i
personally would choose the s21
ultra over the note 20. the note 20
feels better in the hand
it is lighter it looks so much more
premium
and it costs less money now the only one
thing that i wish it could do
is have that high resolution with that
120 hertz display
refresh rate um who knows if that ever
will happen it probably won't
but it is a trade-off you can switch
back and forth if you want
other than that this is still a great
performing phone and it looks awesome
and it works great so you guys let me
know your thoughts
down in the comment section below i
guess the only way the s21 could redeem
itself is with
amazing photo quality and of course we
will be testing that out soon
so click that circle above if you guys
want to see that blind camera comparison
and also with that you can help us reach
600k subs before march which is our two
year mark that would be
absolutely amazing go ahead and check
out one of those videos right over there
this been max and i will see you in the
next video